foreign
hello
hey David
okay
[Music]
foreign
make you a co-host here
and Vladimir
foreign
yes yes hello
thank you guys for those wonderful
presentations I know it was a big block
of time but it was great
goals
just so you guys know we have like some
prep time here before we
let the rest of everyone in so we'll
just kind of wait for the rest of
everyone to pop in and then we can
discuss how this is all going to go down
thank you
foreign
good morning good afternoon everybody
um you're joining the panel discussion
uh entitled The Power of omics
um sponsored by Therma Fisher Scientific
we have an exciting
topic today we were talking about the
tackling the virus research problems and
why we need to deploy proteomics to
complement genomics tools
um joining uh us are not only the panel
panelists today but
um our audience and if you are
participating in the session and you
have a question I would ask you to hover
over the lower part of your screen and
you have the ability to uh you know
click on the chat box and then
ultimately submit the question or raise
your hand to be able to ask a question
as I said this morning we have an
International Panel of
um panel speakers here that you may have
actually seen the presentation earlier
today
um so joining us this morning from uh UK
is uh Max Crispin he's a professor of
glycobiology at the University of
Southampton
um the second panelist is Vladimir
Carvalho he is a
researcher in Brazil
um and uh he has already given us a very
nice presentation around the
around the detection of covid-19
further panelist is tianingu he's a
researcher in China
is joining us from China this uh today
we have also
uh Danielle Swaney
um she is a researcher assistant
professor at UCSF
and then we have
David joining us from the from the UK as
well
um uh given given his background he's a
great panelist uh for the discussion
this morning hopefully have not uh
missed anybody but let's get right to
the actual discussion here
earlier this year
um when the SARS pandemic started to
gain foothold
um across the globe
um the scientific Community quickly had
to respond developing tools
um that detect and track the human
infection as well as the virus itself
using dna-based Technologies
however
um equally impressive and fast was the
actual engagement of the entire research
Community to understand more about
the SARS virus itself as well as the
response of the host the human to to the
actual virus and
um you know I think many months into
this pandemic have a lot more
information around the virus itself as
well as the disease
um I would ask the panelists to give
their perspectives in
um how the role of non-genomic
Technologies were understood or
addressed in their particular covid-19
situation and I'm going to start out to
uh with Max here to let him um you know
answer this question
well thank you very much I mean my um my
initial thoughts on that was really a
broader one which was
um how the technologies that have been
developed as part of other vaccine
initiatives uh were sort of redeployed
on mass and that it does include genomic
genomic stuff as well so um all the
developments
um and infrastructure that have been
built up through large International
consortia what was quite amazing was
just the speed in which it was all
deployed and you know in our particular
case characterization of
glycoprating-based vaccines uh the
understanding that understand the
modifications is an important quality
control parameter an important thing to
have view on was you know we just
rapidly
um rapidly sort of applied to that we
also were looking at mass spectrometry
as a way of um you know assessing
different batches for serological
analysis so right from the start it was
all all applied very rapidly
thank you maybe I can pass the
microphone over to Tien and go uh you
certainly were uh you know one of the
first Laboratories who was you know
drawn into this particular uh research
hey it's a great honor for me to speak
here so actually I received my medical
training you know the city where people
the wealth discovered for the covid-19
uh for the first time the virus for the
first time so uh when I was in China
actually many of my friends and
even family members are in the city of
Wuhan so we we really were worried we
really want to do something and it was I
think we are very lucky to be in the
field of proteomics uh in this with the
technology that we have we can actually
measure many uh host response to the
virus from the human specimens that we
can potentially got but it took us a
great actually a very very long time a
great effort to to get the specimens
through a very safe way so and I think
proteomics can do many things that
genomics cannot do of course genomics is
very critical to identify and diagnose
the virus but it doesn't tell the
disease cause it does not tell us how
the patients grow into severe cases and
also
um protectionists can tell if we analyze
the issues from the patients then we can
get very deep protein understanding of
what the molecular changes and going and
what can be the potential molecular
targets so I think proteins can do much
more than what we have done but you know
from a clinic point of view many doctors
they probably don't really understand
how powerful is mass effect based
proteomics so I think in the future
probably through meeting such of this
type we can have more people understand
that the power of Protonix
thank you
Anna thanks for the perspective
um I would like to pass on the
microphone to David and and have him uh
provide a perspective
hi yeah
um I guess we were in a slightly
different position we were already
working on human chronoviruses at the
start of the pandemic so we were
actually finishing up work on the uh
nasty or uglier cousin of SARS Kobe 2
which is MERS Coronavirus so actually we
have a very large data set on that as
well which is just sat on my computer
waiting to be uh written up and finished
um very so strangely for us we simply
dropped the MERS work
and uh repeated some of the basic stuff
we'd done on murders on SARS Kobe 2 and
um
for us the the proteomics uh side of it
was really informative but actually and
I know I'm biased obviously
um but actually we found the
transcriptomics was super helpful
because it enabled us to actually search
for these novel deletion proteins that
we found straight away uh that the virus
seems to spit out
um with every passage that it makes and
the ability to confirm proteomically
what we were seeing in terms of genomic
deletions has been very powerful
um so I think um
it it to me it's an interesting question
because I I don't
think of doing proteomics in a
non-genomic environment anymore I always
think
straight away to how we're going to make
a bespoke list
and look for the proteins that are
perhaps not obviously supposed to be
there
um but the power of com but
interestingly if you tell somebody oh
I've sequenced the transcript and uh
there might be a deletion of something
somewhere they they just don't seem to
believe you until you say and I have
mass spectrometry data that proves that
it's actually being made and then and
then their face lights up and they stop
they stop thinking you're just waffling
away
I know I feel like I'm waffling away
but anyway I think that was um that was
our perspective I guess it's slightly
different because we were already doing
chronovirus work
at the beginning so it was
yeah
intense times at the beginning that's
for sure
yeah I think it's very impressive to see
that uh all of the you know
researchers that were already working in
this field had to suddenly shift their
focus and uh obviously we were all built
in a proteomics is built on the genomic
technology so they're definitely
complementary and as someone who was
much more exposed to that particular
Topic in terms of detecting the virus
was a Vladimir I I and and maybe you can
describe a little bit what you have been
uh experiencing and providing your
perspective
okay thank you thank you for the
opportunity so I'm going to give my
perspective from the clinical diagnostic
point of view
I I believe that genome Technologies are
still unbeatable in terms of sensitivity
and as also
previously mentioned mentioned it
provides our main uh substrate which is
the sequence but I see a growing role of
mass spectrometry infections this is
Diagnostics in our land you were still
using uh the method I present today and
mainly for our patients located in
distant locations here in Brazil and it
proved to be an important addition to
the economic methods
and uh I think it's important to
emphasize that immune acids are also
essential to understand the Dynamics of
the disease and maybe the combination
the future combination between
antibodies and mass spectrometry
we will have a bright future future for
sure
thank you uh for that perspective
um let me pivot over to Danielle and and
and see what what her perspective is uh
on on the current uh you know challenge
we have as a scientific community
yeah I mean so we so I work very closely
with the lab of Nevin Krogan and we've
been focused on studying viral biology
um for the past 10 years HIV Dengue zika
we've just been going through them and
doing protein interaction studies and
really the focus of you know where we
see the utility of proteomics and what
we do is understanding the mechanisms
that drive the biology of a given
disease and so you know when the
outbreak hit we thought from that
perspective that that we really go come
from and and what seemed you know to be
missing is that we needed hypotheses
about what was going on in the biology
I'm sorry scoby-2 and what sort of
biology was being hijacked and we
thought you know I think this is a place
where proteomics can really very rapidly
generate hypotheses about What
mechanisms are being hijacked from the
host perspective that genomic
Technologies can can really complement
but not necessarily do in the same way
such as you know the phosphorylation
patterns looking at other
post-translational modifications as well
the correlation glycosylation all of
these things
um that the virus we know that many
different viruses utilize these
mechanisms to their advantage
thank you Danielle uh obviously every
every panelist here has a slightly
different approach
um to contributing to elucidating these
um mechanisms and how the virus uh you
know behaves and and ultimately
contributes to the covid-19 disease
um
that that's incredible Insight that
actually has been generated within a
very short period of time and and in
fact I'm trying to keep up as much as I
can throughout the literature but it's
actually overwhelming
um
you know how fast we're moving uh in in
gaining new insights
um but what I'm interested in a little
bit is maybe finding also out what kind
of technical limitations or technical
challenges you've had and
um obviously if you could overcome those
they would probably contribute to even
faster insights and so maybe I start out
with again with Tien and see what what
what what he experienced uh as he was
very early on in this in this pandemic
a challenge to come up with information
and insights
hi thank you so I think there are
several technical challenges you know
actually I'm mainly working on Dia
before I work on the Kobe 19. so we in
the beginning I want to really want to
use a DI for uh analysis of the spasmus
however it's well known that when we are
known as the serum samples we really
want to see the relatively low abundance
proteins which are maybe in cytokine or
other
immune related proteins by the way it's
a Dia currently the proteomic deaths
cannot reach what we could expect so so
that I have to resort to TMT and the
extensive vaccination to identify those
samples and in the beginning due to the
concern actually public concern about
the biosafety issue we could not even
perform depletion
of the high abundance proteins so we
have to really uh no choice we have to
perform the actually that did sample
preparation in the PSL
two or three land to process summer so
you know we can only stay there so our
students actually in a full secure and
we have only a few hours to perform the
digestion so we have we cannot do
overnight because then you need to enter
the room twice so we we have a very fast
digestion so I think in a future we have
a really want to push this to clinic and
meet the public
needs probably we need some very
efficient digestion method and we have
we should have a very safe way to
collect examples and transport samples
to a special lab which we can process
the samples into baptize so we did it
but I think the a lot of space to
further improve in this regard some for
handling and proteomic depths so but now
we analyze actually several hundreds
almost up to 1 000 samples with TMT but
then there's another challenge is the
data analysis well TMT the the in each
study we use the one control to generate
the ratios for for normalization between
different batches but if we have another
study which is a different control then
it's very difficult to compare the data
from this Center to another Center
unless you use the same control but if
you let's say if we analyze the lung
tissue in one batch but you're analyzing
heart in another batch then the
comparison of the protein protein
expression between the law and the Heart
is also very challenging we we still
don't have a very good way now we are
using a mixture of different tissue as a
pool so that contains some lung protein
and some hot protein but then I think
this is not ideal so I think we still
need a better way to in terms of
protein convocation across clinical
Center and after we publish we also have
some requests from International and
laboratory some people analyze the serum
used in swaz some people analyzing using
ntmts some using labor free then how can
we compare data how call how can we
validate some biomacker for different
centers it's not not only sharing data
is one issue but the value
the nature of the value which we
regarded as quantitative intensities is
different so this is another technical
challenge that I think need a future
collaboration to deal with thank you
thank you and then certainly
um you know the the within the hopo
mission here to think about not only the
sample preparation consumable issues
that you've addressed but also around
standardization so uh you know
International efforts can quickly uh
build on on each other and uh you know
you can utilize data uh created in other
Laboratories uh let me pivot over to Max
and ask him about you know the the uh
you know the the the challenges
um and how he addressed them
well some of the early challenges were
not so much technical it was time
um we were conscious that everybody was
uh
um there was basically an international
you know effort to try and disseminate
information as quickly as possible so
what the technical challenges were that
we would normally take an awful on time
dotting every eye Crossing everybody
doing all different orthogonal methods
uh and on this particular case we we
jumped and we just used
um you know one method uh to and
repeated it several times where the
technical challenges came in was low
abundance irons and the fragmentation
quality and we were using a fusion and
you know ready thermoid develops you
know more advanced analogies so we were
very grateful to have the support of the
thermo Labs we ran some of the samples
on on their Eclipse we're actually in
the process of getting an eclipse just
the timing wasn't quite right so it's
now getting installed but anyway so we
were able to verify by a lot of our you
know more low abundance
targets and that was a great support so
yeah there was no technical limitations
uh such more more practical ones
thank you Max and very similar to what
Dion and I already mentioned right that
working in an in a constrained
environment when you handle the virus
but also not only having the tools
available that that you have at this
point in time yeah
um so maybe we can we can we can have
Danielle uh you know give her give her
perspective in in the challenges she had
to face
yeah I think
um very similar to what TuneIn and said
had um you know the first challenge was
just getting the samples out of bsl3
um there are only one protocol and it
was just basically poor methanol on
things and weight and
um and then it and then we were allowed
to bring them out of bsl3 and then we
had to ship them from Paris
to the United States and start working
on them here um so that was a technical
challenge just getting them here and
then you know at the at the point when
we did this study it was the beginning
of April so we were only allowed to have
two people from our lab in the building
they only everyone else had been
prohibited access to the building so we
really had the technical challenges of
making sure like the mass specs were
running for example at that point we
used the Explorers 480 for this
experiment we had only had that
instrument running for a couple weeks so
it wasn't even optimized properly for
this sample type but we were just in a
hurry so we just okay this seems good
enough in hindsight we can do much
better than what we did here after
giving it a little bit more time for the
specific
um Dia approach so I think that was
um some of our biggest uh technical
challenges
in this type of experiment is just
moving quickly and with with the
limitations we had in fact when we got
the paper under review one of the
reviewers said this was a very uh
strange way of doing phosphoproteomics
experiments with the lysis and always
said this is the only thing that the
pasture Institute would let us do that's
what it was
interesting again
um challenges around access to the
actual equipment
um was that similar with with the effort
you had David
um yeah I mean fortunately because we've
done MERS work
um we already had uh
uh protocols that were ready to be
repeated for an activation of the virus
so that that's the key challenge we we'd
validated methods of killing the virus
so that the the samples could lead the
lab safely and be taken down to mass
spectrometry which is fortunately just
the other end of the building and not
not on another continent or anything so
we had that advantage
um and also
um Kate heason who works with us um
she'd work with us before on uh other
nasties like Hendra virus which is also
a nasty zoonotic that kills people and
so she's gotten quite used to being
being taught to handle really dangerous
virus samples that we've assured her are
definitely dead
um
so I think that's the that was the first
sort of real technical challenge
just to sort of repeat all the tests you
have to do to make sure the samples are
definitely killed by the process of
harvesting the infected samples
um so I would imagine that that for me
is probably the the key problem we had
to face just but fortunately we were
used to it
um so yeah in some respects that wasn't
that big a challenge I don't think I
think the other issues we had was that
um you know looking for novel or
interesting proteins predicted by
um our transcriptomic analysis
um having to flip over to climate trips
in or other
um proteases that
um
that presented some slight challenges
um fortunately our facility is run by
somebody who's whiz bang at it so I
don't I guess I don't see the worst of
the technical challenges
so maybe you have asked of aldermere
quickly on how he
um you know overcome those challenges
and and then maybe I have a follow-up
question to what David said
okay so so here in Brazil we do some
more prosaic challenges such as the
access to raids in the chemicals which
is really difficult uh Here Local
Distributors don't usually keep a lot of
items items in the local stock and
importation might take up to three
months
so we had to improvise a lot here and
come up with Solutions based on items
and tools that we had in our hands uh
for example we installed UV lights in
our liquid robotic Handler uh by
ourselves in order to be able to use it
in a safe way
interesting so maybe as a follow-up
question to the to the panel here
obviously you know some of the issues
with access to either instrumentation
um or you know consumables
um you know probably can be can be
addressed through investment in the
future so every every laboratory or
every institution has access to the
appropriate tools in a in a time like
that but more importantly I think is the
fact that there's probably an
opportunity to
um you know take the time and put now
the protocols as well as the
standardized procedures in place so the
next time we do need to you know pivot
as a community and compare data that we
have to imply so
um you know both TNN as well as David
and others have indicated that you know
maybe we should have protocols Sops
ready to go for not only standardized
workflows but maybe also how to handle
viruses Maybe and you can you can start
us off here
so I think definitely although there are
so many challenges we did find some
interesting biology and also give some
value to the other medical community and
the biologists I think they welcome the
contribution from proteomics but looking
into the future I think
I think identify the lower balanced
proteins from a plasma very little
amount of plasma can be very useful this
can be used to evaluate the host
response to the viruses I think not only
to South Kobe too but many others and
this has to be high throughputs and the
unique benefit of proteomics is the
protein is not easy to be degraded like
RNA and it has more information than
being so I think protein protein is a
very great value here and during our
interaction with clinicians you know
many patients they are receiving blood
draw every day will have a couple of day
and also they have the urine samples
collected so if we have a high so good
ways to measure the lower balanced
proteins related to immunity from these
specimens which can be very very useful
for the clinic
so although I'm we're using a lot of TMT
these days I think for inter laboratory
comparison probably
Dias more it can be more useful in the
future and or even use a TMT problem we
can find a way to perform
relatively uh I mean it's a lot of
absolute quantification but if we can
get intensity of the peptides instead
only the ratio this can be more
Universal when we compare data from a
different laboratory and compare data to
di or DDA so this is thank you
so I wonder I can pass on the microphone
here to uh Danielle and do you think
there's a role for hupu now to you know
you know organize
um you know maybe standard protocols
from sample preparation all the way down
to data acquisition both for probably
the viral characterization as well as
the actual host interaction
yeah I mean I think
uh sometimes the perennials Community is
not so good at coalescing around a
protocol but I think it would be a
useful time to make a standard protocol
it probably
um you utilizing you know open source
software for example for data analysis
so that it's accessible to any
researcher I think that would be really
nice even
um you know certain reagents
um you know like certain companies
provide
um they have isotopically labeled
standards that are many like plasma
proteins for example or phosphorylated
peptides that could be useful for
standardization across different
Laboratories
Max you have a perspective as well here
yeah my main one is a slight caution
against over standardization I mean one
of the most remarkable things about this
pandemic is that you know many hospitals
and University Hospitals Labs across the
world have been able using the tools at
hand in that pragmatic approach to
validate and extend our understanding
and so if we were to have to agree to
particular standards that's going to
suit some very well-founded and
well-funded Labs perfectly but it might
have the adverse effects of excluding
all those really valuable contributions
from all sorts of different angles so if
there was any way of developing that
idea of standardization I think it needs
to be done very carefully and and
considerately and in a very sort of
flexible way I think the main area which
could be done is on the sort of
regulatory area you know like biohazard
safety protocols
um approval for a fast tracking vaccine
work
um all that sort of pre-agreements
material transfer agreements thankfully
those were thrown out the window largely
people cooperating and tidying things up
and after the events but I could imagine
a pandemic response where all of that
Frameworks are put in place but like you
see more emphasis is slightly more on
the legal and Regulatory and all that
sort of stuff and less on the precise
protocols because we need to empower
people to be pragmatic I think
yeah thank you
um I'm going to uh see whether we can
actually pivot here for a minute uh
halfway into our discussion to take up a
question uh the question from the
audience is how realistic would an MS
approach for alleviating testing issues
around pcrb or Ms more illusive for
other aspects of virus research like
disease mechanisms and disease
monitoring so I'll pass this on to
Waldameer who has been focused on
detecting the virus using mass
spectrometry and and see what his
perspectives are
uh yep and to believe that mass spec is
is feasible and we are we are showing
right now that it is I think there are
many uh challenge to to overcome yet for
example standardization it isn't is a
very important Point as you if you just
mentioned but I I'm not sure if it will
be possible to consolidate uh all simple
prep in just one protocol
because I think each level would have a
particular needs and equally conditions
on the other hand I think it's mandatory
to make all the data available through
open software uh like for example
Skyline that can
try to make the data more more
comparable comparable comparable
thank you now I'm extending this
question a little bit to David
um you know how realistic is the MS
approach for alleviting testing issues
or how much of that Ms is more you know
suitable for disease mechanism and
disease monitoring and personally you
know you know reading a lot of the
literature I I sort of I'm still uh
surprised that we haven't come up with a
different test other than trying to
detect the virus directly when it seems
to be more important to actually know
whether the person has The receptors and
in in this particular case also the
protease that needs to be present for
the virus to be incorporated maybe you
have a perspective on that
foreign
[Music]
I think the pro the problem is is that
uh
we don't fully understand all the
factors about attachment and entry but I
mean you know I think I think we're
fairly confident everybody has Ace two
and European one and the other the other
things that are needed to get in
um as for the proteases that that uh
the buyer seems to skip round the
protease problem by just modifying the
spike glycoprotein so
uh if it deletes the fury and cleavage
site then it can use
um uh Temperance independent methods of
getting in and then presence velocity
Temperance it keeps the fury sign I
think in terms of using proteomics on on
clinical samples that's
way outside my expertise actually we've
not really done any of that and kind of
work
um
so I'm not sure
um how far
um that is of use except except I know
for example from colleagues here that
have done a work on blood proteomics in
Dengue infections
uh yeah the biggest problem then of
course is is getting a reliable
biomarker and that's sounds easy on
paper but he's uh murderously difficult
so yeah sorry I'm not it's not really my
area of
uh understanding to be fair
um so yeah so I can't can't give you a
more comprehensive answer
well thanks David but you brought up an
important uh topic which is to
glycosylation and if you uh you know
seen some of those animations uh you
know the spike protein uh in itself is
highly glycosity the Max has definitely
contribute a lot of insights to that so
I wonder whether that he's whether you
see
um additional ways of providing
information about either the virus
itself or the infection
um as well as the disease progression by
you know involving sugars in a lot more
um you know in a lot more of these
um insights yeah it's actually a really
complicated area because these
glycobrasions often capable of
interacting with carbohydrates you know
like some of the glycamina glycans some
of the
um some of the features
um
um you know like highly negatively
charged carbohydrates for example from
cylic Acid so when you start to consider
the interaction you can look and
consider the dynamic X of the sugars
attached but actually as a secondary
effect you've got all these other
interactions going on that do augment
and enhance infection so unpicking it
what's local you know to what degree do
the processing states of those uh and
the presence of sugars and the immediate
binding Partners influencing it is an
important thing to just to look at and
investigate but the wider one is to what
degree do these secondary interactions
enhance and I think the the field is
very much shifting towards appreciating
their importance and of course the
analytical burden that place is on on
the problem is um you know clearly
becomes a lot more complicated
thank you um in in that regard what
brings up the the next question right uh
you mentioned biomarkers uh we mentioned
biomarkers before uh both Danielle and
Kenan have done work in their uh
Laboratories to sort of figure out how
the body responds or the host response
and and where there may be
um areas of therapeutic intervention so
I'll let Danielle talk a little bit
about you know what she thinks is the
next step here to uh you know walking
towards a therapeutic intervention
I mean I
I think that
um you know our phosphorylation study
did a really good job of identifying
um
drug potential drug targets I mean we
had about 80 candidates and half of them
in cell culture models were effective at
inhibiting viral replication so I think
now we just need to be more
comprehensive doing these types of
studies in different cell types
comparing those across coronavirus so
what does this look like for MERS SARS
cov1 things like that to understand if
we can identify drug targets that are
applicable pan in a pan Corona fashion I
think those that'd be really important
as well
just a quick follow-up how long do you
think that may take
I think I mean we're working on it I
think
I think people should be working on it
because everyone uses different
protocols and brings a different
perspective
I mean another thing I think that would
be really interesting but it's
technically very challenging is to you
know we did a lot of protein interaction
studies using overexpressed viral
proteins but it'd be really interesting
to try to do this in a live infection
experiment because certainly there's
cooperation between different viral
proteins and understanding that
cooperation and how that affects protein
complexes in a more native environment
of infection be interesting but then it
can be difficult to
um you know bring that out of bsl3 so
probably a cross-linking proteomics
experiment might be the way to go to try
to address some of those questions
interesting and pasta the question on
now 2T and then um as Danielle said um
you know we we don't know when uh
antiviral drug may be available
um I think your laboratory has done a
lot of work to sort of understand where
the various uh points of interactions
might be
um that's um yeah we can identify some
this regulative proteins from uh human
specimens that can be potentially
therapeutic targets but back to the
other question I think our lab working
more on the biomarkers for diagnosis for
example diagnose What patients will
become severe this actually is very very
important question in the clinic because
most of the individuals infected by the
virus do not really need to be to
receive special treatment only a small
portion but how to identify this more
portion is very important and the other
also you know we observed in clinic some
patients did the nucleosis remains
positive even after three months and
nobody knows why because this patient
received the same treatment as the other
patient most of them turns negative
within three weeks so why some patients
students become more stay longer for
positive and this generate a lot of
public concern so then we found actually
from the blood we can detect some
proteins and metabolize which indicate a
immune suppression and this may be
actually
treated to reduce their positivity
appearance so I think the study we did
the data looks very promising we we have
a few clinical Center in China their
specimens confirm these results however
we cannot really put this to Clinic
because no in China
unfortunately basically there's no no
covet patients
around our city and the province so I
think in this regard International
collaboration can be very important so
you there some people are interested
from an audience or from collaborators
we are very happy to work with them to
to move this forward currently we cannot
do this in China
all right uh appears that there's still
a lot of infections going globally
though
um in you know there should be samples
available
um you know we have talked a little bit
about you know the the mass spectrometer
is a complementary technology for in for
for the genomic approaches in fact a
little bit about the contributions that
mass spec had in terms of understanding
the disease uh understanding the virus
itself
um I want to trickle back to Max and and
ask him the question around the virus
itself and how much we understand today
you know only six months after we
basically were exposed to the to the
challenge and and and ask him a little
bit you know where do you see this going
in the next few months you know do we
see the same progress happening in the
next six months
wow that's a big uh big question and I
think you we we have to break it down in
terms of what's what areas of activity
and what degree of progress we're going
to see so to take things like the
Diagnostics I mean clearly
um that's becoming incredibly
sophisticated uh the access to the
sophisticated technique so uh not
uniform so I think that that needs to be
brought out
um interestingly my Spectrum she has a
big role in having sort of reagent free
analysis so you know actually my
enthusiasm for Mass spectrums you've
been census agent and the next pandemic
is really high you'll solve a lot of
problems worldwide in terms of the
progress
um obviously a protective vaccine I
think is an important component of the
global strategy not every country has
managed to to
um to handle the virus and I'm very
optimistic so from what I hear a lot of
very different strategies are producing
very encouraging results so that's um
that's you know I think as the Escape
for optimism of course the big barrier
is not then scientific so much it's you
know getting access to this and
distributed and I think that's going to
be the next really big um thorny area is
just how quickly this can all be
disseminated when when I hope success is
submerged
interesting I sort of pass on this to
David who essentially has been working
on viruses for a very long time and and
see whether he has insights in that
particularly as you compare this
particular
challenge of you know identifying the
mechanisms around sars2 virus versus
previous or other viruses and you
mentioned nurse in that regard several
times
um
well from a virology perspective it's uh
um it frighteningly it just feels like
it was only a matter of time really
SARS was very dangerous but not easily
spread MERS is also very dangerous but
not easily spread and this virus has hit
the Sweet Spot it's uh in relative terms
actually not very dangerous and it is
easily spread so you get presumably
I mean one of the Hallmark is usually in
viruses that are easily spread is you
get really good replication in the upper
respiratory tract so above the neck
which means that the viral load in your
saliva is very high
which means that when you talk or cough
there's tons of virus coming out of your
mouth
um
and that's not conducive to a virus
that's super lethal really quickly
because a virus is super lethal really
quickly it's just gonna have you on your
knees and bedridden fairly in a fairly
short order and also actually that tends
to come from viruses that replicate well
in the lower respiratory tract deep down
in your lungs
um and this is this is kind of thing you
we knew anyway from studies on influenza
um
so
um I think yeah in a lot of ways this
was kind of inevitable and I think Max
Manson the next outbreak I mean yes
they're definitely there's a good chance
there'll be a SARS Kobe 3 or a MERS Kobe
2.
and there's also the you know the
ever-present threat of a new strain of
influenza
um uh so I think in terms of what we
need to do going what people need to do
going forward I think probably yeah we
probably need to spend a lot more time
getting good vaccines ready for every
class of virus there is out there
because of course there are no effective
vaccines for coronaviruses at all uh and
that's not for one of looking I've been
looking for one in animal chronoviruses
for 40 years and not found one
um so whilst that hopefully the vaccines
were that are in trial now and and in
the pipeline one of them will work it's
by no means certain
um
so I think that's one of the things we
need to do in in terms of
yeah what's going to happen over the
next six to 12 months
well hopefully one of the vaccines will
work
that's my best that's our best hope
um I think some of the ideas around
drugs uh such as uh what you know the
sort of approach taken by Danielle and
that they're they're fantastic uh ideas
and certainly very useful the problem
with the maze is that as a virologist
um you're reasonably comfortable with
the idea that as soon as you've found a
good drug device will mutate around it
um and you lose its efficacy fairly
quickly so you'll probably want to
restrict those drugs so only the very
sickest of patients while we wait for a
good vaccine
um so yeah I'm
that's what I'm hoping for in the next
six to eight months is a is an effective
vaccine and then we've got the next
challenge then of what does the virus do
once we vaccinate everybody
because once you've done that you've
then you'll then put an evolutionary
pressure on the virus which it has not
so far had to face
you know there are still a good seven
billion people to go through for this
virus
um
and it's not under any pressure
whatsoever at the moment
in evolutionary terms
thank you yes
um
so we've talked a little bit about you
know how Mass spectrometer contributed
to solving the many open questions
um we had and still have and hopefully
they will continue
um I wonder how the the last six to
eight months have changed the way you
collaborate uh tiananm you know
mentioned a little bit early on that he
said I wish I had access to a more uh
comparable data set so I could you know
I could take my data and and utilize
other Laboratories data
um I'm more interested in to find out
whether you see a different way that
Laboratories interact and you know
scientists interact in the future
whether that's with other Mass
spectrometer Laboratories or with other
disciplines within within their
institution and is there any learning
that that came away from the last six
months and and how particularly the tool
of mass spectrometer is going to help
other disciplines in moving forward
Maybe be even start with TNN on this
question
this very good question actually
I feel the covet I mean Kobe is really
really bad for the for the world but for
science it's amazing that everyone wants
to do recovery research so I mean uh
relatively small University with a
multiple colleges we have a School of
Science we have a School of Engineering
I like science and engineering and
everyone wants to contribute to the
battle against the Kobe 19. so we have
Engineers who make robots
who proposed to make robots to the per
Santo in a PSO three lab although this
actually this needs a lot of efforts we
didn't really work because he cannot
access psl3 lab and we have a computer
scientist who wants to to text the
mining or apply deep learning to the
all mixed data that we generated of
course this has not a success being
successful too because we don't have
that amount of data for
deep learning and however we have a lot
of discussion and not only in our
University but also in other cities and
with clinicians and the clinicians they
are the the as I told you
you must reply so we have a clinician
who have a patient who's a nucleus it
remains passed after three months and
she has a great pressure to make this
patient active otherwise the the
hospital is in the highest security rate
but there's no way he tried everything
he tested but the patient still positive
so he he will ask whether we can using
proteomics we can find any clue with
other approach cannot find any clue he
just try randomly select those drugs and
there's nothing really works so then we
identify the some protein related to
T-Rex and we found T-Rex
approaching in those patients so then
they see she's very happy and and this
is the really a great way to for her and
she's really convinced that proteins can
do something in clinic so this is our
interaction with the clinicians this is
really good and also with uh after our
paper
is even not published by cell but it's
just online
then receive a lot of emails from
different fields some people from
chemistry some people from of course
many from proteomics and they just asked
me uh some protein appeared in our paper
because he's been his whole career in
studying that particular protein so I
only focused the small portion of the
900 proteins that were Quantified so
normally we pick a few and explain but
then I suddenly realized the whole world
since I'm looking at this regular
proteins from their own perspective it's
really amazing I think this year
is really a great way for collaboration
and people realize the value of
proteomics
thank you definitely a very interesting
example here or two interesting examples
of how you've been interacting with
other colleagues um a sort of passed a
microphone to valdemir because I think
in terms of interactions with clinicians
you know pandemic is still very active
there in in Brazil I wonder whether
whether you have you know extended new
network profession that were beyond the
colleagues you have worked with as part
of this this uh pandemic
yes sure I think our in fact all of you
see here in our institution were
desperate for for some uh alternatives
for for testing Diagnostics and the uh
didn't know in our uh idea in the first
second and they had been very
collaborative collaborative and trying
to
make us uh more uh
which will help us to develop more
specific and more sensitive tests and I
think overall we have collaborated much
more than ever uh before and detected
several uh synergies among uh once maybe
unrelated Specialties and I think I
think the idea of the continuity between
genomics and Protonix was was reinforced
it was very important and their input
during our method method designs was
really crucial
and I think this is very extremely
important to feed in their source for
example to track
mutations and the virus evolution
and I feel that immunologies are still
sort of isolated and I believe that mass
spectrometry would be a link between
genomics and knowledge in the future
thank you interesting uh uh pastors on
the caution under Danielle and I know
she is part of a team that you know as a
mission statement has the the the you
know with trying to bring as many
researchers together and certainly the
Publications that came out of out of
their you know your team uh and your
colleagues uh you know was was it was an
indication of how much collaborative
effort was going on in a very short
period of time
yeah I mean
um over the past several years
um Nevin Krogan the director of the qbi
has basically been traveling the world
establishing these collaborations
through lots of symposia all over the
world and then um you know once the
pandemic hit
we already have these collaborations in
place we had relationship with these
different Labs a lot many of them
involved in virology research thought we
could just turn to and and really get
the ball rolling so we didn't have that
initial hurdle of like hey do you want
to do this it was just almost implied I
think you know one of the other things
that's really different
um from since the pandemic has started
is that you know being a proteomics
person I never have any shortage of
collaborations constantly people coming
to me saying I have this cool biology
can you help me look at it with
proteomics and now I think that things
have kind of swapped
um where you know I code of them I say I
have this really cool data can you help
me validate it because that's the
missing piece to publishing this paper
and so it's a unique position I think
for the proteomics field to be in and
driving some of this work in that way
instead
interesting
you know again Max do you see it you
know similar
um efforts of the community pulling
together and in the new way
yeah it's been just tremendous frankly
and obviously no one would want to wish
these circumstances on the scientific
Community but it has shaken up a lot of
um a lot of people in so interacting
with new people even in the same
institution I imagine the same sort of
apologetic conversations like I'm sure
we should have spoken more over the last
few years so it's broken down a lot of
internal I don't say barriers but you
know like rekindled links internally
also internationally whereas it might
take a little while to to get
collaborations going now I think those
are enlightening you know lightning fast
so
um I do see a slight shift now where
people are starting to have to go about
you know business as normal they've got
their pre-existing obligations but I
hope that this this culture of just
looking a little bit further afield and
and being quicker to collaborate will
continue
fantastic
um so I think we're pretty much up on
time here
um it was a you know very insightful
conversation here with respect to mass
spectrometer as a complementary tool in
in the buyer's research as well as as
part of the uh covid-19 response I think
we've established that there's still a
lot of opportunities in terms of you
know creating the tools necessary to be
more responsive whether that is giving
people access to the tools providing
more standardized methods having access
to the chemistry when you need them but
there's also uh you know a very bright
on side of this entire uh covid-19
situation emerging which is we have
learned how to come together as a
community uh you know quickly because
you know become a larger team uh if not
within the organization or the campus
but actually internationally and and
contribute to to you know the the
insights that we need to have to you
know effectively create a Therapeutics
as well as a vaccine
so with that I I would like to thank all
the panelists here for you know taking
the time uh sharing their experience uh
from the last six months uh as well as
their insights on how we should move
forward and I propose that uh as part of
the uh Hupa meeting later next week that
we you know maybe send the message to
the Huber organization let them know
maybe we should have
a sub team formed around vital research
where we start to discuss the issues on
standardization as well as some of the
protocols that that may be available
next time when we are looking for a way
to deactivate the virus being able to
change methods being able to provide
access to either chemistry or methods uh
and with that I see a lot of people
nodding again thank you so much for your
time today appreciate it and um have a
good day
bye bye thank you so much